well the highlights was Victorian
Christmas market the mayor and I opened
it on front last Friday on one of the
coldest and wettest days of the year but
it was absolutely packed and that was
the following day where you could you
could hardly get through there were so
many people I think it demonstrates this
is really a very successful part of
Stratford's year and I think we heard
thanks to all those members of staff in
this council who work so hard to put it
on
along with those from the town council
as well and then finally those who some
of you might know there was an election
the other night and it was notable for
one specific reason it was the last time
that we will see David all be acting as
our returning officer and David joined
us in 2016
he's not only in democratic service
officer but he has I think overseen a
huge increase in the quality and choice
of training for councillors and indeed
parish councillors with a wide range of
courses and I'm Fred I haven't attended
every single one an awful of them do
seem to clash with Chairman's events
which is disappointing but next year I
shall look forward to joining them again
but thank you David I think you've
really uplifted our our training and
then of course as I said returning
officer and David said to me yesterday
all his many many elections he's been
involved in and it's been I mean for
those of us who turn up we vote on one
day if you're campaigning thing it's a
little bit more challenging but David
it's a major bit of work for his team on
top of all their other day-to-day jobs
and so I'm sure all councillors would
like to join me in thanking David for
doing an excellent job as returning
officer and looking after all of us
as a democratic services at that point
we will move on and I will now invite
the leader of the council to oppose his
important Thank You chairman first I'd
just like to say that when I was out of
action for a month it really brings home
just how much is actually going on and I
would like to express my personal thanks
and appreciation to council pemberton
for Easterling efforts in a very
challenging period I have to reassure
him that I did not pick the time off
just when it was meant to be a
challenging period so the second
announcement since the elections in year
in May it's been an extremely busy and
challenging year for the council the
challenges just kept on coming I think
it's a tribute to both staff and
counselors how well with Colt I do think
we put many of the challenges behind us
now they're putting in place the
foundations for a much more effective
and better future third I make no
apologies for the length of this next
announcement councils working in
partnership with settled and the
3,000,000 group to provide help and
assistance to our EU residents across
the district the main goal is to inform
EU citizens in the UK of their rights
pulse brexit and make them a word of the
need to apply for settled status to
remain in the UK after briggsie and live
their life as now for those councils who
attended the training here in November
we were all made aware of the complex
issues surrounding residents needing to
apply it was actually quite salutary to
listen to that in Stratford there are no
organisations receiving funding from the
Home Office to assist and inform
vulnerable EU citizens that's why we're
supporting
reach activity with access data from our
lateral system and identified four areas
to hold outreach events with two events
arranged in January in Ulster and
Biddeford details of in circulated to
all councilors I have to say this
initiative has my full support
EU citizens living in the district are
our responsibility and we should do
everything we can to assist them and
finally a bit of good news between
Monday and Wednesday of last week the
High Court in Birmingham heard the case
between SDC in the Greek trustees
regarding the future of the Greek site
in Ulster the judge held that the SDC
claim was legitimate and awarded SDC
possession of the site from 31st of
January we are currently working with
the trustees to manage this transfer I'd
just like to comment that this has been
a long drawn-out saga that has soaked up
an immense amount of valuable time thank
you
Thank You leader I'll call on the head
of paid service for his announcements
just the one you've already congratulate
David in relation to affection but I'd
also like to congratulate all of the
team on conduction of the election last
week it was a fantastic team event and
together so quickly I think was
remarkable so thank you to all those
involved on the day the count thank you
again
it is thank you David
we therefore now move on to well there
is no we've had no questions from the
public
so item 5 we move on so I with with your
approval members I'm proposing as we
have had a request from net brailles
doesn't it yeah if we could take items
and 11 and 12 neighbourhood plant
neighbors development plans
now and then we'll go back to the normal
rest of the order as put forward
so taking 11 first clevedon Neighborhood
Development Plan I can't invite cancer
down Pemberton as deputy leader of the
council to introduce this item thank you
Thank You chairman the the collaborative
Neighborhood Development Plan group had
been working on their their plan and it
came through to its fruition at a
referendum on the 24th of October where
the plan was endorsed with an eighty
four point zero one percent yes vote on
a turnout of just just under thirty one
percent so we are now at the position
where the clabber that clabber the
Neighborhood Development Plan which you
will see as impending once you report
can and should be adopted with immediate
effect to the consequence that it
becomes part of the development plan for
stratford-upon-avon districts and may I
just take this opportunity to thank the
volunteers of the collaborative
Neighborhood Development Plan group team
for all of their hard work and also pay
thanks as well to two officers in the
policy team who first supported the
group in bringing the plan forward so
hopefully we can just move straight to
the recommendation so that we can use
the document from that so do we have a
you're proposing this do have a seconder
Richards all those in favor of adoption
of the cavitus Nevin thank you carried
with Apple move that's darling we've got
2.12 brailles Neighborhood Development
Plan I cut some pemberton could you
Thank You chairman once again this
neighborhood development plan for
brailles has reached its referendum
stage the referendum was held on the
21st of November and the community
endorsed the plan within the in this
plan and eighty-eight point seven eight
percent vote in favor of adopting
plan on a turnout of just under 36
percent once again we're now at the
stage where the brailles Neighborhood
Development Plan which again is appendix
to your report papers to your council
papers should be adopted with immediate
effect with the consequence that it
becomes part of the development plan for
stratford-upon-avon district and once
again I'd like to publicly record thanks
to the members of the brailles
Neighborhood Development Plan for all of
the hard work that they've put together
in bringing forward this this document
which will be which will be pivotal in
helping support the development team in
in future developments in Briers and
also again would like to thank that
policy team for hard work that they've
put together in supporting the NDP group
in bringing the plan forward so I will
be proposing that the recommendation on
page 75 of your papers that the plan be
adopted with immediate effect and I'm
just looking for a seconder Thank You
mr. picker I think you just beat beat
everybody to be the second door on that
one oh we can't slow feet I'm sorry we
are we agreed on that one
agreed thank you okay so that is both
neighborhood development plans and I've
been adopted congratulations to both
villages for they've achieved I think
that brings us to a total of harmony
with 15 parishes in district we've got
quite a long way to go I think there's a
hundred and seventeen settlements in the
district that we are clearly beginning
to make an inroad and some of those are
quite some of the ones that represent
larger communities who that will move on
to 0.6 and had a paid service returning
offset electrode illustration officer
and deputy returning officer I call
counsel Tony Jefferson has due to the
council to reduce his item Thank You
chair the employments and appointments
subcommittee duly appointed Debbie
Buckland to the position of chief
executive with the appointment
commencing on the 28th of October there
are three separate lots of fine C and
we'll take them in order so it's
recommended to council the Davy Buckland
be appointed head of page service from
Monday the 28th of October 2019 if we
take one individually then are we agreed
Thank You lieutenant
then the statutory role of head of paid
service
this requires council approval counselor
requested to appoint David Buckland
chief executive as we've just appointed
him as head of paid service to the
council for the purposes of section 4 of
the local government and Housing Act in
1989 with effect from the 28th of
October 29th a thank you are we agreed
[Music]
and finally looking at the returning
officer and electoral registration
officer the recommendations are that
David Buckland chief executive they
appointed his returning officer an
electoral registration officer with
effect from the 1st of January 2020 and
that Caroline Nash Democratic Services
Manager be appointed as deputy returning
officer and deputy electoral
registration officer with effect from
the 1st of January 2020 I'm sure all
counsels be comfortable with taking
those two points together are we agreed
thank you
that concludes therefore item 6 we
therefore move on
could I just offer my congratulations to
David and Caroline on their appointments
[Applause]
close i some seven proposed changes
number of committee seats I invited
cousin Tony Jefferson as leader produces
item I hope this is a very
straightforward item I just to explain
how a recent change to the political
balance on the council has affected the
allocation of seats on council
committees hunter proposed changes to
the number of seats on certain
committees in order to more
appropriately reflect the current
political balance so the recommendation
is that with immediate effect the number
of seats on the following committees the
increase to the following regulatory
committee 11 auditing standards
committee 9 was to co-opted employment
and appointments committee 9 planning
committee a 9 and planning committee Bay
9 and now I am rather assuming that
nobody has agreed to adjust the number
of seats in another way that still
complies with the legal requirements
anybody wish to make any comments in
response to that nope in which case are
we agreed to support that proposal
thank you we therefore move on to 0.9
officer Employment Procedure rules I
might cut took counsel Tony Justin point
eight point eight dogs I take pictures
before we got there
senior management Reconstructor and
changes to Constitution and white coats
attend Jefferson has lead to the council
produces item Thank You chair the
purpose of this report to seek authority
to make necessary changes to the
Constitution as a consequence of the
decision to revise the senior management
structure and that minor amendments to
the terms of reference for the planning
committee and delegated powers to the
head of technical and community services
are set out in the appendix to this
report being approved
basically can I have your approval to
those please so we'll have any comments
that wish to raise if not are we agreed
to support that proposal thank you now
copper excited everyone we are now at
number nine and therefore I would invite
again counsel Tony Jeff's introduces
item officer employment procedurals
lieutenant thank you chair just to give
the background to this the office of
employment procedure rules explain the
processes by which we recruit a point of
discipline and dismiss employees the
recent senior management debris
structures provided an opportunity to
conduct a review of the document and the
version attached as Appendix 1 to this
report reflects the outcome most of the
text in the revised document remains
unchanged from the current version
and some of the changes are a direct
consequence of the new management
structure and the replacement of two
executive directors with the chief exec
and deputy chief exec the revised
document does not and I would stress
that seek to change the level of
involvement of members in any of the
processes by which the council recruits
appoints disciplines or dismisses
employees so with that the
recommendations page 43 are the existing
office of employment procedure rules be
replaced with the revised version as set
out in Appendix 1 to the report with
immediate effect and that minor changes
to the terms of reference for the
employment violence committee is a
consequence of the changes to the office
of appointment procedure rules are set
out in appendix to be approved with
immediate effect thank you mr. Grafton
monster I would just like to share a few
words yeah Thank You chairman on your
desk you will find a hard copy sheet
that's relevant to this appendix to this
item just to say that the hard copy
sheet on your desk contains some changes
to the appendix as it appears in the
agenda and it also slightly changes a
version that you may have received last
week by email all the changes that are
suggested are marked in dark gray on the
sheet before you and secondly on page 51
of your agenda you'll see that there is
an appendix 2 which is suggesting slight
changes to the terms of reference for
the employment and appointments
committee there's one gap in that
document it's a bullet point 6 it begins
with the words to determine incremental
salary increases for the
post and it should read for the chief
executive post I just repeat what the
leader just said none of the changes
envisaged will affect the substance of
the report itself all the two
recommendations the changes don't affect
the level of involvement of counselors
in any of the processes and in summary
what we've got is a three tiered
approach where chief officer posts are
and will be appointed by the employment
and appointments committee or a
subcommittee of that committee as will
any disciplinary action any dismissal
etc statutory officers their appointment
and dismissal will always be a matter
for full counsel with one slight rider
that disciplinary action against a
statutory officer is again a matter for
the employment and appointments
committee and lastly any other officer
in other words player officers who are
not either chief officers or statutory
officers
that's the province of the head of paid
service so there won't be any
involvement of counselors in that but I
hasten to say once again those are not
changes to the existing rules at all
does anybody have any points they wish
to raise on mr. Grafton's comments if
not are we agreed to support that
proposal so we now move on to item 10
review of contract Standing Orders and I
invited Tony Jefferson as leader of the
council - excuses item Thank You chair I
keep having to stand up just the context
for this the law requires a local
authority to make standing orders with
respect to contracts for the supply of
goods or materials or for the execution
of work we've adopted contract standing
orders as part of the Constitution which
have been amended from
time to time as required which report
recommends the council replaces its
existing contract Standing Orders with
the proposed contract Standing Orders
are set out in appendix warm to the
report although there will be some
modifications which mr. Grafton will go
through the intention is to bring the
changes into force on the 1st of April
2020 to allow sufficient time for staff
training and to coincide with the start
of the new financial year and just
referred to in the text is the Official
Journal of the EU and if one actually
looks at the categories on with the
public contracts directive 2014 224 au
supply services and design contracts
that limit is 181,000 Works contracts
are roughly 4.6 million I'm so for
another specific service 615,000 mr.
Grafton would you just like to introduce
the amendment thank you
so there will be a second recommendation
to the report and that recommendation is
that the chief finance officer shall
report every quarter to the cabinet to
provide a breakdown of contracts lit
with a value of over 75,000 pounds so
that gives you an extra vision over what
is happening in terms of contract awards
there is also one very small change on
page 57 which is paragraph one point
seven point four you'll see at the end
of that paragraph there's a reference to
paragraph C 16 of the of the rules
themselves and that should point back in
fact to C 2 where there's a definition
of what the guiding team
other than that the report stays as it
is with that with subject to that one
additional recommendation Thank You mr.
Jefferson I'm very pleased that the
additional recommendation has been put
in place
it gives cabinet the opportunity for
oversight of the pattern of contracts
and I think it is an excellent addition
to the paper so with that the
recommendations as outlined by mr.
Grafton
yes finished because I just want to say
thank you to one other change that does
not be referred to which is under the
Environment and climate change
implications a new requirement is there
that consideration must be given to
carbon reduction factors at the pre
procurement stage which is a thank you
for taking on board one of the things
that came through the task and finish
group thank you happy with that we got
any other comments anybody we should
raise on this item
in which case are we agreed supported
right go through so far I'm not
impressed convinced so we don't with
numbers 11 and 12 so we now move on to
number 13 and then it's rated for
treasury management strategy for the
mid-year review 2019-20 and I call upon
Council Harvey this finance and assets
portfolio holder to introduce this item
Thank You mr. chairman when I'm like 13
yeah
this paper briefly deals with the
council's treasury management activities
and the chords they sits at a statement
stretchy statement of the expected
activities after the for the current
year the cabinet acknowledged that the
video reports been prepared in
accordance with required standards and
it's covered the items which are set out
in the paper there are seven items there
and the council is recommended to
approve the treasury management
statement for the immediate review of
the treasury management statement for
the current year it's presented Thank
You mr. chairman Thank You councillor
Harvey does anybody have any questions
for councillor Harvey or wish to raise
any items on this item
nope in which case are we agreed thank
you we now move on to order the
standards committee meeting of the 18th
November 2019 and first item 14-minute
409 for to the cultural shuffle on Aven
District Council I invited penny on
O'Donnell to report on this item
introduce his item Thank You mr.
chairman
and consideration was given by the audit
and Standards Committee to the findings
of the external investigation into the
culture at strap to Nathan district
council the findings and recommendations
were accepted and proposed actions
supported I therefore ask the council
that the report be noted thank you Saeko
Donald does anybody have any questions
for Kelly O'Donnell on that item nope in
which case are we agreed
number 15 minutes for 11 electoral
viewership on Aven on that councilor
penny on O'Donnell as chairman of the
subcommittee towards use this item thank
you sir
and the timetable for further electoral
review of strapped and even by the local
government Boundary Commission for
England was considered by the auditing
standards committee but commencement
during spring 2020 and any new
arrangements to come into effect in May
2023 accordingly I asked the timetable
be noted thank you any questions anyone
who raised any items in which case can
we move the recommendation are we agreed
thank you
we therefore move on to appoint
16-minute for 112 colors of meetings and
I invite you might recognize like
councillor penny on O'Donnell was
chairman of the Audit Committee produces
item thank his chairman the calendar of
meetings for 2020 2021 and provisional
calendar of meetings for 2021 or 2022
were considered by the audence standards
committee in order to assist councillors
and officers in planning their Diaries
well ahead to note where possible every
effort has been made to avoid school
holidays I therefore ask the council
agree the calendar of meetings as
presented Thank You Council Baca
when the meetings on I'm very glad that
we have fir wood moved out to school
holidays but I would like to make a
proposal that the timing of the meetings
the full council moved to four o'clock
in the afternoon I realized the timings
are not on here at the moment but I
think it's an appropriate time for us to
consider it my reasoning and that's
supported by those I've polled so far on
this is that there are certain numbers
of our members between us who have
full-time jobs and to be here I have to
take a days holiday and if we don't take
a days holidays some of them just quite
honestly cannot attend particularly one
of my colleagues is a teacher for whom a
two o'clock start is absolutely
impossible so my proposal is that we go
for 4 p.m. starts 4 full council does
anybody have any other points they wish
to make or would you like to respond to
that counselor Donnell and then I'll
invite mr. Buckland to make sure that
he's comfortable with that yes
interesting note that you just mentioned
before this is a combination place I
actually think we would be better being
in an hour later there isn't it better
public participation when they finish
work rather than we are available to
more like to have people are retired or
are not non-working capacity if we had
to open ourselves to public questions in
the end we are probably stuck we need to
probably start looking at our start
times I think 2 o'clock is a bit
ridiculous in the modern world not for
work purposes I know obviously it has
not an effect on myself with we're
trying to sell our childcare but I'm
also aware that as a council we should
be looking to increase public interest
through ourselves and that likes that I
would like to go for a slightly late to
start still because most people don't
finish words about 5 o'clock and we need
to think a bit more practical and I
think even if we don't pass anything
change today we should certainly get
some sort of group together to try and
get consensus to get a timely to
maximise public involvement within
council meetings thank you Casterbridge
can I just check do you have a second if
your proposal council barker you do
council pemberton right cousin George
come back cancel all those crimes it's
good to seek advice really because I
completely agree with the proposals
I'd actually agree with the later start
to engage more with people of working
age in in the workings of the council
but I'm not sure how to proceed with
that as chair of auditing standards but
I do completely agree with the proposal
and support the later start even with
myself my last monitoring officer to
explain so this amendment would be
before council now so your role as
audits at audit and standards that chair
is at a debt because council has
delegated that matter to the auditing
standards committee but it is still
subject to ratification from Council so
council can debate this today and make a
decision comes with krump Thank You mr.
chairman yeah I do tend to agree I'll
even be slightly more radical and
suggest 5:30 because the two reasons one
again makes your people available in two
to try recruit more people of working
age unto being cancerous and again if we
can do the 5:30 that can potentially
have their childcare arrangements sorted
out picked up from school etc and then
coming time to come to the council
meeting
that's my two pennyworth thank you
come we have a proposal which has been
seconded
I just like to pick up some other views
and then I want to find out whether
there is support for a different timing
to that put forward by council Barca
Scouts of Junod yes it is actually
something that the Lib Dems used to call
for before when I was a counselor before
to have evening meetings and actually
we're an anomaly in the area Warrick
district council first for instance
starts at six o'clock in the evening I
think it's only big councils like the
County Council that meet in the daytime
almost every other Council meets in the
evening whether it's four o'clock five
o'clock or six o'clock I think
perhaps it's something that you need to
consult on but I'm not averse to the
idea so if you want to start with four
but make sure that you get you have some
consultation because a it does include
it does encourage more counselors to
stand who've got daytime jobs and it
does encourage more public consultation
as well so I'm happy with that but again
there may be in individuals within the
council chamber who have a different
point of view I would have liked to have
had some consultation on this beforehand
but it's where we are thank our student
council frankly in thank you chair
personally I don't see any reason why
this council student follows traffic
Town Council and started 6:30 right mr
Fielding planning o'clock stop they
think so if it does Rumble on too long
you have got a problem of the time linen
casserole
can I suggest that we send out a doodle
poll to everyone and take the majority
at the end of the day giving giving for
5 4 4 35 536 and ask people and take
majority do oh thank you coach Roth mr.
Buckland chairman thank you I mean the
item before us today is that to agree
the calendar of meetings and and well
really to discuss the start time of the
meeting so what I was going to stitch
was something similar to mark Council of
office just suggested that perhaps we
also do not understand this committee to
consider this and come have a report
back to next meeting the council to
determine the start time of council
meetings in the new municipal year
council barkuloo referring to the new
municipal year or the meeting for the
25th 4th of February onwards okay I'd
suggest though because there was no
consultation but ahead of the meeting
whether we do take just some time to
consider that and come back to the next
meeting the council without so old it
audience and this committee for report
this is not a complicated question which
doesn't involve an examination of last
month's of papers and so I don't wish to
do can't throw Donal on the committee
out of some exciting piece of work if we
could actually come to a conclusion
today and therefore what I'm going to
suggest and I will take cancer Pemberton
councillor Rock sorry Catholics comments
in a minute but what I'm going to do is
on a show of hands if I've read out a
number of options and then by show of
hands see which the most popular and
then if we can have a propose for a
second to for that as popular option
subject to be approved by members yes I
know you've put a proposal forward but
we may need to amend that proposal by a
in accordance with our normal procedures
so can we have counsel that's what I'm
thinking we might try and do but
counselor Pemberton two or three
different type times being suggested
however with due deference to members in
the town there are district councillors
that represent the entire district and
have parish councils that ruin a
different sign so I think to be fair
chairman I think we might struggle to
agree a set of times here and now where
people may have to check back with their
own wards around future parish council
meeting so probably on a practical level
the opportunity for that to go back
through toward and standards where
members of the opportunity just to check
their own their own forward calendars
for parish councils because parish
councils do exactly what we do they
start to forward time meeting so whilst
it would be great to get ourselves a
time agreed here and now I'm probably
feeling that actually members will want
the opportunity to check back with their
own wards about approach council times
and that to inform and then we can
perhaps come to a good if not perfect
solution so that's probably what I would
be thinking and I think I have the that
the proposer here with her a sense as
that for a way forward Thank You Council
Rock Thank You chairman council
Pemberton said exactly what I was going
to say so I would propose an amendment
to the motion that said exactly his
words that I think we all respect the
objective of the proposal can I propose
an amendment that we all go away and do
exactly what we need to consult our
forward dies because I've got a lot of
parish councils exactly for that point
so come not think about the wording for
that amendment to say let's go away and
come back to the next meeting or to
audit standards having thought about
what the amended time should be let's go
forward with that
I can think of some were you but the
combination of what mr. bottner said and
what was kind of a pendant and said it's
what we should be doing
Thank You mr. Grafton wishes right so
I'm getting the drift that councilor
Pemberton and councillor Barker are
willing to withdraw their motion because
it's a friendly amendment in which case
if you've got a seconder Castle Rock
then it becomes the motion I would
second council rocks proposal Thank You
councillor all cook thank you okay yes I
I do also believe this needs to go back
to audits because there's additional
information which I'd like to request
including additional costs to Council
regarding offices time outside of
standard hours so yes it's sort of been
thrown at me and I'm still trying to
think on my feet of exactly additional
information that would be required for
me to go ahead and be like I have enough
information to vote on this council
Bromwich suggested was going round you
know this motions I would suggest that
obviously we've we're pretty much agrees
that we need to look at times
how about rather than put forth motions
today and emails circulate to each
councillor on their preferred option as
suggested by councillor of they're
saying these are time options and that
of it and then when we come to the next
meeting here at full council then we can
turn out and say either yeh or made to
that rather than curry nod cleco melded
circles Thank You council borage Council
frankly Thank You chair
we've been visibilities testing time so
you're so disgusting which day of the
week
Monday cut cuts are off not only do we
have to consider offices time but
obviously if we start a meeting at 5:00
and it goes on till half-past eight some
of us might be hungry
I want dinner now well I'm just thinking
we are entitled to claim free meal
allowance and that's flex to cost right
mr. mr. Buckland has kindly drafted a an
alternative resolution and I'm going to
ask subject to mr. Ralph still
supporting it and the leader seconding
it that the order of the standards
committee be requested to consider at
the start time for council meetings
following consultation with all
councilors are you happy that that
correctly reflects mr. Wakile
interpretation and you're happy second
that all those in favor of that
resolution right carried we therefore
move on to the second what's actually in
front of us which is the recommendation
of council which is the calendar for
meetings for 2021 be agreed and the
color of meeting for 2120 to be proved
on the basis of these being provisional
dates to assist counsel with its forward
planning and we agreed with both of
those thank you we we therefore thank
the council Donald fuel contribution on
that we now for now move on to cabinet
item 17 I invited evidence reduce this
item as deputy leader council members a
numbers
cabinet meetings not to December
calendar
[Music]
that's right sorry withdraw that the
leaders going to take it and take that
on I ask Council to receive the minutes
of the cabinet meeting on the 9th of
December council junit I just want to
reiterate what I've said I said at the
cabinet but also at the bag that given
that some councils across the country
have found ways in which they could use
the regulation one two three lists in
the past but also now ifs going forward
for infrastructure that would meet
Climate Change Action Fund requirements
as and as a way forward just to
investigate and report back to the task
and finish group or or its successor as
to whether that's achievable thank you
does anybody have any other comments
kind of leader do you want to say that
to all the gathering could come back to
council joonas comment cabinet and spag
accepted and understood so moving
forward then are we agreed on on that
item Thank You counsel 18 item 18 minute
436 child of a garden waste service icon
the portfolio holder councillor Shenton
to introduce this item thank you the
proposal I've got to say it was never
going to be popular and I understand
that so I'd like to take a few moments
just to run you through some of the key
areas and also to say I thank everyone
that actually responded to the public
consultation and for taking the time to
complete the survey you bear with me of
my year I've got man flu and throat's
starting to two weeks ago the cabinet's
reviewed the responses on proposal does
take the counter of some of those is
financially driven in the main and
there's no hiding from that our options
for raising funds are limited
raising the council tax instead is not
an option
that's all one of the reasons why not
would be why should someone who doesn't
have a garden actually pay for the green
waste collection charge the proposal
will help the medium term financial plan
allowing the council to become more
agile and resilient to changes in
central government funding it should
also be remembered that some climate
change initiatives will need funding and
failure to approve this proposal could
compromise our ability to respond
positively to financial requests
simply put annual charges will be 40
pounds per wheel bin or reusable sack
this charge was the most favored charge
in the consultation a twelve and a half
percent or five pound early bird
discount will be offered to residents
who sign up before the 1st of May 2020
if a resident only needs to use half of
it they can opt to share it with their
neighbor there will be a communications
program as well to explain the scheme to
residence with a frequently asked
questions section cousin was also
looking at the possibility of an
education program in schools on waste
43% of the responses said they would use
the household waste recycling centers
which use the windrow method de compras
this is environmentally friendly and is
being the good neighbor and very green a
point raised in the consultation was
that of the collection of food waste
there will be a collection for
presidents whether they subscribe or not
and then on request they can have up to
three of food caddies and their 10 meter
caddy is about this big and I meant to
bring one with me and apologize for that
these will be collected and emptied on
the normal green collection day just
briefly returning to traveling to home
waste centers and and particular
fly-tipping I'll deal with the
fly-tipping issue
first well as one of the points that
people raised though they would be
increasing in fly-tipping
well fly-tipping is illegal for a start
no evidence in the health or ''tis that
we surveyed and benchmarked against
there's no evidence that fly-tipping
increases slight if intends to be the
big ticket items white goods waste from
building that sort of thing not green
waste so and on the subject of traveling
order even dumping of waste the
Stratford Herald just took by way of
comparison is delivered to you does not
deliver to your doorstep unless you pay
for that service it costs 80 pence for
80 pence a week or just over 11 P a day
we will return up with your doorstep
pick up your bin not me personally empty
it put your bin back where we found it
and come back every two weeks come rain
or shine to me that sounds like
excellent value for money
it's important that the conservative
Lake council deals with the difficult
issues as they arise not by hoping that
the problem will go away or that we'll
deal with it on another day we are
determined to do the right thing and
make sure that the council is
financially stable and able to meet the
challenges it faces in potential further
reductions in central government funding
and the climate emergency obviously to
do nothing in my opinion would be an
abdication of its responsibility and the
responsibility of councillors of all
parties I ask all councillors of all
parties to approve the proposal in its
current form and I'm happy to take
questions it's my voice again
Costard unit on Friday I got my email of
the resource giant journal to which I
subscribed and the resources and waste
strike strategy had put out an email a
press release calling for an elegant
review a relevant revival of the
resources and waste strategy and the
environment bill and the legislative
program allied to it now that strategy I
will have a significant impact on local
authorities it proposes an introduction
of a separate collections of food waste
but also free garden waste and for every
household in England the wording in the
strategy makes it clear that there will
be consultation on that but also
consultation on the impacts and the
costs for local authorities and it makes
it clear also that there will be
promotion of anaerobic digestion and
quality will compost and digestive
digests state standards given that that
this is you know going forward that I
think that we are extremely premature
one of the things that I want to see is
being able to see that some of the
material that collected is used for
purpose with proper compass up to proper
standards or even better to be used for
biofuels I think we will need those in
the future but also this consultation
was inadequate
despite the question the answer to the
question on the paper I believe that
there was a material error in the
consultation that clearly influenced a
number of replies that the council had
already had a 60% reduction in
government grant funding it may have had
a 60% grant from reduction in one sector
but not overall and then thirdly the
other area that have question all the
way through is fairness because somebody
that lives in annex council house with a
very long garden and not and maybe on a
pension
certainly has as much of a need for this
as maybe somebody that's in an extremely
large house and fourthly than what other
thing that I wanted to ask about is that
if we choose not to take on the green
garden you know ourselves what will
happen to the bins I'm certainly not
intending to pay for the for the green
bin what will happen to my bin who will
collect it because I don't want to see
lots of green bins ending up in the
local River the 60% reduction I accepted
that was slightly misleading slightly
misleading and I think catch the hobby
he's going to cover that off shortly as
far as fairness that is never going to
be an absolutely perfect solution I
think that that's the top and bottom of
it it's as fair as it can be it's as
simple as it can be
we can't start just discriminating
against one section or more than one
section of our residents we have to go
with the simplest option otherwise the
administration of this we just becomes
incredibly expensive pensioners you
mentioned pensioners and that I've got a
big garden well if we think about how
long we thought for the running we're
looking at maybe the equivalent in the
first year of one pound seventy a week
up to when the scheme comes in after
that we're looking at 80 pence a week
we're not looking at 88 pounds a week
we're looking at 80 Venturi
I think it still represents good value
we can again how would we administer
that that would be it would be difficult
we stopped the way of in one area we
then have to look at it a bit to be fair
to everyone we then end up with again
the ministry's nightmare as far as the
bins go if you don't want you binge you
just ring us up you just ring the
countertop and let the other ones be
collected
it isn't really as simple as that and
there were say there will be a
communications piece going out which
I'll explain or how all of this will
work counselor forchick I think it's
more moral principle at the moment it's
a universal service and I think it's a
form that it's it covers every household
I know if they are going to put forward
that some households don't have gardens
but it's a universal it is a universal
services other services that the
District Council provide that aren't
universally used by everybody in the
district so you can't pull the hardened
that some people are can the user
because you might do that for every
service that we're providing that the
council provides so I think they I think
it's the the most important thing to say
is that what other services will the
council charge for in the future and I
think that set this sets a dangerous
precedent as far as our unconcerned and
also I'm really concerned that it's the
poorest that will be hit the hardest
regarding this as well if you include
services that are within the council tax
it has a tear those that had the wider
shoulders paid more in council tax those
who are the poorest pay less in council
tax it's not the fairest tax but it has
some kind of tear associated to it a
40-pound charge it's 40 pound for
somebody that earns eighty thousand
pound here but it's also still a 40
pound charge for somebody that may be on
a minimum wage thank you
I'm super sorry Jenny
I've got real concerns over the
prematurity of this because the
government is going to be reporting back
within the next six months if we do take
some radical decisions in our spending
money up front to actually change what
we're doing and the government does come
out and say this should be a free
service across the country we're
actually making decisions before and
spending money before we need to I do
think that is something that we've got
to think about because I'm not I'm not
aware yet that the government has taken
a view on this I think there's been some
riding around but I'm not sure that
we've got a view on it yet I do have
some concerns about the collection of
food waste as well residents have the
option at the moment of putting their
food waste into their green bin rather
than their grave in it really isn't
happening on a big enough scale food
waste is going regularly regularly into
the bin that goes to landfill and that
is a real difficulty because it's
actually producing methane etc etc the
education that needs to go forward to
actually get people to actually use
their food caddies is really difficult
because people don't like having that
Green County full of it's not slimy
smelly food outside their kitchen it
there's a big resistance to using it the
other thing is that if we're actually
going to reduce we're going to take away
the green bin we're going to increase
the transport of cars up to our home
reclamation sites that is going to have
a carbon footprint of of its own so I've
got some real problems here and I'm not
convinced yet that this is the right way
forward
I need more convincing Thank You
councillor council Pemberton
Thank You chairman I think we follow
this under making a difficult decision
and we have to make difficult decisions
first of all if we think about the
suggestion that the government might
ultimately decide that green waste be
delivered free currently green waste is
not a statutory service it's a it's a
service we provide over and above the
services were required to provide for
the council tax being no doubt
whatsoever but if the government decides
that green waste will be a free service
it'll be free in name only we there will
be a way in which people will have to
pay for that there will be a cost
associated with it so you can either
have it as a discrete charge for got for
garden waste already rolled in somewhere
else as we stand at the moment there is
no indication that the government are
about to launch into suggesting that
garden waste become a free service if
that changes at some point in the future
then we may have to be flexible and
review how we do things what is equally
clear is that there is insufficient
Headroom in council tax to make the
financial impact that we need by virtue
of this charge okay the direction of
travel from a central government is to
move towards local authorities being
more self-sufficient we also want to be
able to invest in other things such as
climate change activities so one way or
another we are all going to have to pay
for these things the suggestion that
people are just going to suddenly jump
into their cars and take their garden
waste up to the local did I'm sorry but
for 80 pence a week by the time you've
cleaned the back of your car out by the
time you've driven it once you won't do
it a second time this is a good value
service and that just gives the light of
the notion that hundreds of green bins
are going to be returned I have yet to
see anybody who says I'm so pleased to
be playing for the grant garden waste
service I would give my children for it
in that old will you see license fee
kind of a way but the reality is
everybody says they ain't going to pay
it but they look at the look at the
value
I look at the cost they won't be
returning their bins there's no evidence
anywhere that fly-tipping increases
councilors Shenton by the way may I just
comments as councillor Shenton is our
style councillor for today take us take
a look at this so people won't be
returning their bins there's no evidence
of fly-tipping
increasing with any other authorities
fly-tipping is by and large about the
big white goods no one's going to be
started dumping large amounts of green
waste on the side of the road
councillor fridge is absolutely right
about the education piece about food
food caddies and we will have to change
people's attitudes and views about that
but we're offering through caddies we're
offering discounted composters so for
those people who feel that the charges
are is burdensome there are going to be
other options we will be fried in access
so you can compost at home which is
actually a even better solution and I
think one one wagon traveling into
Biddeford is better than 25 cars driving
out of Biddeford to to the to the waste
sites so I think it is a difficult
decision but in the round I'm not seeing
any other choices so on that basis I
think we should all be getting behind
this answer and to go with the with the
charge cards for Adam Thank You Chet I
think it's fair to say that management
of the green waste is critical to the
way in which the district approaches its
carbon strategy I would contend that
this isn't a simplification of the
scheme I believe this is actually a more
complicated scheme and that's been
reflected by the residents who have
contacted me who are concerned about
this and have said flatly that they will
not take part how that comes out in wash
in terms of where the waste goes is
something that is not certain and saying
that there definitely won't be fighting
is there's something I've sort of
contend is very hard to be definite on
but ultimately as has been accepted that
there is misleading notes within the
report
I would say that there isn't evidence
that has convinced me that this is the
right scheme and as a representative for
my ward and my local residents I will
not be supporting this that counts for
okok Thank You chair I just want to do
at folk affectation please cancellation
turn it you mentioned about having money
for climate change and climate change
emergency that needs to be implemented
are you saying the money raised from
these green bean green bin charges is
going to be ring-fenced to be used for
climate change emergency things we have
to put through or is this money actually
just going to be taken into the rest of
Council thank you for those points I
think just run through the other points
I would just pick up wrap up at the end
coach the Bromwich counts the crumbs gas
questions Bertie's had to run off but
luckily we've been thinking on the same
lines here so first observations of this
I know we're saying 80 pence a day
actually so H pence a week so eight
pence a week may not sound a lot of
money but for starters I'll tell you now
a lot of people were like even sell them
that they've got better things to spend
their 80 pence a week on and I could
pull up the phone now today get up
social media because it going on there
just before I set off for the council me
meeting
I don't bombard abide notifications will
just use the great bid that that will be
simply people will not pay 40 pound
they'll play in the gray bin but the
major point here is in the summer we
voted two o'clock to support a climate
emergency now we're going to try and
charge to discourage the use of
something that is environmentally
friendly if you're going to put a big
charge on surely it would be the gray
bin to discourage the use of that rather
than your
other things now that would be a logical
thing but playing the charge on a saw
bin is really a big death especially
when you've been offering it as a
service for free for a long long time
people do not like to change now it's
alright so we can try and educate
through leaflets advertising campaigns
now but we only have to look and see the
realities of that you probably look
through somebody's door if they're like
most people I know it's a quick look and
it's in that bit they don't tend to read
them they don't those been clearly state
on them now what uses are meant to be do
people actually genuinely do that the
answer is simply no they don't often I
see every day where every Friday when I
Drive down the street this is been a bit
undue haste and bringing interest on the
first two to what I would actually be
saying to council here is yes we've
realized that it's going to be increased
costs on various any sort of refuse
disposal now whether it's recycled green
or gray bit I think we need to take a
little step back and say rather than 1st
of June 2020 because another issue has
come up on social medias people don't
think they're properly consulted I think
we need to take we set back an improper
plan there is note there should be no
haste bring it in this year so if we are
we should be targeting the first of
April 20-21 give a silent properly to
come on proper plans engage with the
public if you are going to charge
between now and June is not going to be
long enough to get people aware in all
obviously now they just simply will not
you have to sustain a campaign to be
able to get into people's mindset and
it's not going to be just sent a
leaflets round we need to think
carefully here about how we make
ourselves look stupid by trying to make
a charge not so hastily is it better
there actually we have to rush in we'd
probably take a bit more time if we
aren't greedy we're going to bring
anything in on this law so what are the
alternatives put it to the
they put the codes there whether it
should be on council tax whether it
should be a separate charge but the case
and see what people really think because
most people I've tasted a from reading
them comments aside I pay a lot of
council tax I paying for it quit extra
but huge put it on account status counts
or phone check said it is a fair
distribution which would bear that in
mind now but it may not be the absolute
solution we probably need to have a
proper think about not just greenways
but a whole refuse system and probably
give us time to actually reflect of how
we're going to do it and how we're going
to maximize everything it's for the
benefit of not just the council not just
the taxpayers money but for environment
in general and I think that is probably
more sensible move to take thank you
can't surprise just wait disappoint is
it a point of order of information is
that the reference to the free garden
waste and covering the costs of local
authorities is on page 72 of our waste
our resources our strategy for England
which was brought in in 2018 thank you
constitutive council Mills thanks mr.
chairman I don't you miss the point here
but there's no such thing as a free
lunch everybody thinks oh we're two
freeways it's being paid for somewhere
and that's you know eight pence a week
to me it's not a an awful lot okay maybe
a lot somebody but I spoke to my coach
counselors about this and veterans
didn't in my vision came to and I can
honestly say not one they said I'm not
going to pay this this 80 pence a week
as I say there's no such thing as a free
lunch they say so a free waste
collection delivery service then such
thing somebody's got to pay for it
somewhere miss chairman thank you
Kousaka Shelton who everybody else
listed to speak a comes from the Council
Rock sorry it's just a question we were
told that we were going to have some
more information about the finance mr.
chairman a moment ago so I'm I'm waiting
to hear that are we going to get life
nobody else is listed to speak can't
cancel Shenzhen would you like to
respond to the items raised by at least
cancer I've encountered Bromwich and I
think councillor rocks point first thing
councillor Junaid mentioned the
consistency the government report this
is the government report the response
and the response says quite clearly the
sole consultation proposal 7 collection
of garden waste
he says whilst we retain the view that a
free collection would be the most
effective way of ensuring this it is
noted that stakeholder correspondence
were generally not supportive with
particular opposition from local
authorities actually it was 80 percent
against it we will therefore give
further consideration to the costs and
benefits of this measure before making a
final decision on where the green where
the garden waste collection should be
free of charge or whether charging
should be a matter for local
decision-making now that doesn't sound
to me why that's going to be done in six
months that they were there listening to
the councils they realised that if we
don't pay for the council's don't have
this facility they've got to make up
that charge so that really isn't that I
think to be honest councillor Junaid you
may you've you've slanted that -
obviously - to the point you wanted to
make
it's that's the report is definitely
there counselor virtually said talked
about reporting back in an hour story
let's move
are you ever reporting back in the next
six months we come in and hand to some
of the others that delays this is a
report dated july 2019
that's the original strategy this is
this is the government response dated
july 2019 that's the one that we will go
on the green agenda these as far as the
the green issue goes it's a
discretionary service and he's not a
core service it's a discretionary
service the idea of charging for the
graving the graving is a core service
you cannot charge separately for that
the green bin is discretionary we can
the other point is i mean if we talk
back in july we decide we passed a
motion on the green agenda since then
the oversight and scrutiny committee
that's dealing with this and counselor
june it is the the chair have come
forward a number of proposals and those
proposals are likely to totally outweigh
anything that we collect from this now
how on earth do counselors really think
we aren't going to pay for this if we
want to move forward on the green on the
green agenda there is no money tree we
have to be realistic here if we want to
move forward on the green agenda we need
to finance it the medium term financial
plan is quite clear it shows that where
our reserves will go down because of
lack of government funding one way and
one of the only ways we can do it is
through the green the through the green
waste we are not alone up to 70% of
councils at the moment charge with
others considering it some
considerably more than 40 pounds or 80
pence a week we have to be think
realistically here and be pragmatic it's
not a great it's not ideal nobody wants
to pay more I accept that but if we want
to move forward on the green agenda it's
quite clear we have to fund that and
this is the only way that we can fund
this going forward an alternative is we
sit on it if we do nothing we bury our
heads in the sand and say we'll deal
with it another day we can't afford to
keep waiting to move forward on this
it's not complicated it's simple it's 40
pounds charged per bin if you have a big
garden
and most of the gardens tend to me with
the bigger houses though not all and
I'll accept that you up if you need to
bins you will pay for two bins
that's fairer than actually charging
people who live in flats forty pounds
put meat on the counter shouts which by
the way we cannot do there isn't enough
Headroom there to be able to do that
[Music]
cancer and cancer Adam I think said
talked about carbon strategy and is more
complicated it's not complicated at all
actually you read into it whatever you
want but it's definitely not complicated
as for ring-fencing know how could I
possibly give you a guarantee that I
could remove reefers the ring for
instance especially where we know that
the climate agenda is going to cost more
than this will raise absolutely not I
will not give any kind of comfort so
that the graving we've covered there's
several of gravy in charge again council
tax we've covered that how to say we are
not alone it's not likely we're doing
we're doing this just on our own if you
want to go ahead with the climate change
agenda so then this year and following
years we have to be
mystic this proposal is the most
realistic way of going forward further
consultation further talking about it
will not change the basis of it we've
made it as simple as we can we've
deliberately not covered a number of
areas that maybe people would rather we
had covered because it makes it that the
ministry typically very expensive as
I've mentioned I would ask you to think
again I realized over here on the
liberal side you're not in favor of this
and I understand that however you have
to think about the green agenda how are
we gonna finance that there is no point
burying their heads in the sand can I
close remind councillors that once
you've spoken on emotion the
Constitution is clear unless it is a
point of order that you can only speak
once on each motion and I know a number
of people have waved their hands a
second time but we do have two we do
have a constitution for purpose so I
think mine was a point of order Joan
because they're efficient and said he
was going to explain the 60% because he
had misled the council on the 60% and I
thought he said councillor Harvey was
going to explain that
which we're still waiting for so that
was my my question come point of order
chairman so I was waiting for that
explanation of which we thank you
point of order yes just out of interest
counselor Shelton has spoken more than
once
is that okay under the rules are some
monitoring EPSA so if you have put
forward a motion that at the end of the
debate the proposer has the right of
reply mr. Jones Kelso Shelton would you
like just to respond to mr. rockbind of
order - the rock and if you look in the
councilors questions which is why I had
said that cancer Harvey will cover this
because it was a question from your own
side from David Catherine counsel Curtis
and there is a there is a full
explanation there
as for the the comments about misleading
people who are them to give misleads
everyone I'm sorry I really I don't
don't worry I don't take offense care
yeah it's sort of rock
mr. Rock right
those who've not spoke previously does
anybody wish to say anything to add to
this debate of the leader who is wishing
to speak in which case nobody else will
speak I therefore called on the leader
cancer Justin to speak Thank You chair
doesn't matter which way you look at it
we facing the squeeze on finances if you
look at the new homes bonus we got 4.5
million in 2019 20 we estimate that will
be new by 2324 and it's going to fall
rapidly the materials recycling center
is actually going to increase I will
cost in other words however you look at
it we've got a squeeze on finances when
it comes to the green waste these
we do not have to provide it it's
optional we cannot raise council tax our
capability to raise council tax is
capped end of story
so and we have to deal with the thing of
him now
it's all very well for the government to
say they do in a consultation how long
will it actually take them to come to a
conclusion so and if the government want
green ways to be collected free then
given that an awful lot of councils
actually charge from the service at the
moment count our government are going to
have to provide the funding and really
when it boils down to it we have to deal
with the here and now and to balance the
budget it may well be that if we come
off charge for this service we have to
stop providing it so be under no
illusions there are no easy choices and
no easy decisions my video is we have to
go ahead and charge for this service
thank you in which case we've heard from
everybody who wishes to speak councillor
Ralph have you have you not spoken
before thank you
do you have a seconder for that so we
have a motion that's been proposed and
second executive I can't suggestion we
we've had a request for this to be a
recorded vote which has been seconded
and therefore I'm now going to ask for
all those in favor of the motion
okay so chairman in accordance with the
contours Council Standing Orders have a
recorded vote in relation to the
recommendation to Council that the
revised proposal is detailing section
for the agenda of the report be approved
in full
I will ask everybody's name in turn and
I'll ask whether you please I indicate
whether you're for against or you
abstain to the motion chairman councilor
kettle for the motion vice chairman
councillor Dixon Adam against Costa
Barca Council bonds is absent council of
homage Catholic cargill comes like leave
against
councillor krumpers had to leave the
meeting
councillor Curtis is absent councillor
Eden against
councillor field in Council of fitter
Khosla Fleming for catalytic Tesla
foreman for counselor Ian freshly
councillor Jenny French Lee canceler
howís is absent
councillor Harvey councillor hench
iseverything
councillor Jefferson Haslett Jennings is
absent councillor Junod as the Kendall
is absent councillor Mills for Kessler
O'Donnell Calipari has the pemberton
councillor Richards Council Reilly
against
castle rock castle roof counselor
Shenton as well Wally Huggins
thirteen okay so chairman the total
number of votes for the motion was 17
and against 13 therefore the motion is
carried
thank you
Buckland right we now move on therefore
to item 19 which is cancer questions and
start seeing first one we have counsel
Edmond you've had a written response do
you have a secondary question Thank You
mr. chairman
thank you counts Henshaw Seraphin you've
had a written response that you have a
secondary question no I don't have a
secondary Thank You councillor Curtis is
absent counts for Jenny fragile II you
thank you for the answers they they do
raise some issues which I think I'd like
to discuss perhaps outside this place
issues perhaps on the provision of
sheltered and retirement housing which
actually raises an issue here and also
on empty properties that could come back
into use for affordable rents and I
think those are two quite large areas
that we need to explore this isn't the
place to do it but I'd like to speak to
you later about that be a great pleasure
to speak to you later Burton thank you
and thank you coastal freshly councillor
JUnit - we've had a response do you have
a follow-up nope
cancer during a duel second question
you've had a written response do you
have a secondary question counsel Roth
you had a response yes thank you
slightly confusing response so I just
wanted a couple of things
I appreciate that if an officer climbing
officer asked for the applicant to
provide a training report but it's not
clear it only says if there's if the
report is unclear that report I think
should automatically whether it's
unclear or not go to the tree officer in
my opinion and I think there's a lot of
people that you know we've had a lot of
trees go which shouldn't have gone and
I'd like to I'd like to ask cuts of
Wally Hawkins if you could provide some
stats for me you say that significant
more trees than we are allowing to be
filled perhaps you could give me some
stats over the last six months how many
trees have been how many new trees have
been replaced by those that have felt
I'd appreciate that thank you
Carly Hagen she we should respond I'm
gonna show Council that Rolf will be
appreciate I'm unable to give statistics
at this present time but one of the
matters that I can assure you is that
when trees are felled there is got to be
a real justification for that and
plainly it's important that know that
we've got our climate emergency but
within parish councils when we get
notice that trees are going to be felled
or if they're going to be cut back
significantly I do think it's our role
as district councillors to encourage
those applicants to plant additional
trees but that also means that parish
councils also have to highlight areas in
which those trees will be welcome too
we planted I will endeavor to get those
figures for you with regard to tree
felling but I'm sure as you can imagine
councilor Ralph that's no easy task so I
will pass that on to officer to try to
get those details to you and I thank you
for raising this matter thank you
we therefore move on to cosa
rock did you have a secondary question
yes please chairman thank you very much
for her answer which is about plastic
contamination from planning signs that
are left up for extended periods and I
also thank you thought of response to
the clip particularly partly cooking
there's a top of the group of papers on
the back and that the planning team will
be looking at this question in the
summer but I would particularly like to
focus in those reviews are the use of
plastics in the first place because it
does degrade and fall to pieces and so
forth so it's not just a question of
leaving it off there's I'm just
wondering if that team could look at
that in in the future as to how we do
that and particularly engaging with
parish councils I'm not suggesting that
the planning officers go out they're
going to remove them because it clearly
would be impractical and costly so I
just asked if you could make sure that
that is considered for all sorts of
alternative suggests as how that
completed so thank you for your question
but it is plastic that which you've seen
mentioned four times in the in the
question so thank you very much for that
could you consider plastic as the
priority Thank You chairman council Rock
thank you bring this to our attention
and obviously a great deal of thought
has already gone into this and the pros
and cons of using the pass the plastic
envelopes that we put the planning
notices in has been thought about we did
look at the council officers did look at
using plasticized paper but again that's
just as bad we have to weigh up the need
for actually publicizing that the
planning application with the need to
keeping them waterproof etc now it is a
legal obligation that we have these
notices out there for the public to see
but I do feel that it's going to be a
role of removal
that is going to be going back to parish
counters and I've gotten the secretaries
that are involved with within that so we
did there are there are plenty of
methods in which because it's not just
about recycling it's also about reusing
and if those plastic elements can be
reused again than that again is you know
the end the plastic if they can be
reused again it's not just a one use
plastic is it the also we need to
remember counselor Rock is that as
recycling becomes more dexterous and
that more amounts of plastic can be
recycled that it is very likely that in
the near future that this type of
plastic we will be able to recycle but I
am very keen that we stop these things
from dissolving on the roadside that we
get some initiatives together for these
removing what officers have indicated to
me is that there will be a more
prominent date at the top of the
planning notices to say when these
notices can be removed by and I think
that that will help people pass us by
and councillors parish councils in
particular to know that they can be
about it and remove them Thank You
councillor on thank you
I think we now move on to councillor
Cleves you've got two questions your
first question you've had a response you
wish to question no thank you mr.
chairman good your second question
Thank You mr. chairman excellent right
racing through we move on to therefore
questions to the leader and comes to
Rolf beat me to it on that one because
we're all thank you chair
I'm going to do a tiny bit of preamble
to this question because I think it's
important since the rather sudden demise
of the link project for the homeless I'm
very concerned that what was provided by
the link is not being provided for at
that same level I am fully aware of the
Fred winter project without which I
fully support but this project will not
start until around 40 next year
meanwhile the homeland comas are not
being provided with hot
food showers home clothing or only one
to speak to quietly in an informal
setting p3 do their best however p3 do
not have facilities for storage for warm
clothes and they do not carry through to
won't run with them the URC and
subsequently the Baptist Church also
doing their best in providing Haven for
two days a week for around two hours
each time even then hot food is not
provided those who do use the Church of
no place to shower I know a few people
some friends who are walking around the
town giving out food and clothing but
even they do not have the facility to
offer hot shower of hot food or showers
meaningful change is not providing these
facilities either so my question to you
leader is what is this counselor doing
on the ground to help these people can
the letter said to be open for half an
hour a couple times a week for the
homeless to have a hot shower can you
find a kitchen which can provide hot
food
I have helpers standing by who are
willing to cook these meals where is the
money budgeted for looking after the
homeless going is it being squirreled
scrolled away from when Fred went to
Center opens leader I think we should
sit down and go through this very soon
but I wanted to let you know that I am
extremely concerned
sorry Thank You councillor Ralph I think
given the big to nature of those
questions I need to do some research and
get back to you which I will do within a
week council forecheck
got slight preamble as well before hours
the question there's a book that came
out last week called four steps and this
is a book by former MP labor and peace
Labour councillors and labor members of
the laws now this book is a series of
resignation letters from the Labour
Party on anti-semitism and the
anti-semitism within the Labour Party
itself so the question is first league
leader agree with councillor Harris on
the anti-semitic comments that she made
to be fair to councillor Harris I'll
give this some context a comment by
Linda wall part of the Jeremy Corbyn
true socialism made a comment I wonder
or if acts of anti-semitism highlighted
by Tom Watson and the other traitors are
in fact committed by agents of Israel
the motto of matzo being by deception
thou shalt do war the direct response by
counsel Harris was spot on
don't you find it tiny that this was
encouraged found and exploded just
before the release of the report on
Israel and war crimes in my mind these
comments quite simply are anti-semitic
in their racist comments the council on
the 24th of April last year condemned
anti-semitism and approved a motion to
adopt the definition of anti-semitism by
international Holocaust Remembrance
Alliance and pledges to combat this
pernicious form of racism in light of
this motion do you welcome her back into
the Conservative Party
thank you file or question counselor
phytate the question is to whether she
will be back in the Conservative Party
will actually be down to the local
Association under group cosa Perry
Thank You chair leader I wonder whether
you would like to join me in
congratulating our newly elected MPs
Nadine Sahar we and Jeremy write to the
district and also Jonathan galas who has
become the new MP for stoke north who is
from stratford-upon-avon Thank You
councillor Perry
I would indeed like to echo your
congratulations for Nadeem Zahara we and
jeremy wright and also for jonathan
gillies for being elected I think it is
fair to say the election results on
Thursday were interesting and may well
occur in a very new era in UK politics
Thank You councillor fredley Ian thank
you care I've raised a few times the
issue with the lights on the bridge that
goes across the from across the basin
and I'd like to thank the council
because I can report that they know
appear to be in full working order and
particular cancer sentence involvement
in it Dan although I think I raised back
in probably about 2013 14 the problem to
the lights on the tramway bridge the
ground lights and they still don't seem
to be working correctly and when they do
work they actually need cleaning
could I ask the leader to look into that
please
I will certainly look into that
counselor fancy a cultural [ __ ] sorry
I'm actually going to bring you back to
the homeless again I understand you are
going to answer countess revolves
question within a week we are getting
perilously close to Christmas and New
Year with the prediction of very very
cold weather I would like to stress to
you chair leader sorry that this is
acted upon urgently and maybe a few days
maximum to up be able to get things in
place before the season is upon us
Thank You council Hall clock I would
remind you that there is a cold weather
protocol that actually kicks in if the
temperature falls below a certain point
which actually does an issue that the
homeless are providing with shelter and
accommodation I think at the moment
speaking from memory across the district
as a whole there are now only six people
who are homeless Thank You councillor
Bromwich yeah I start off by making
declaration of interest on this because
it relates to private hire taxi license
in of this one obviously I have a
license badge holder but this is the
information this relating to what
operates have said to me obviously and
the Sun we declared the climate
emergency but our current council policy
for prime fire vehicles it's six years
from first licensing the vehicles that
has to be up to three years old as is
pointed out a lot these operate
especially small operator have five
years worth financed but the average
life span of a car it's actually close
to 30 years the original reasons for
bringing this in were to maintained a
very high stance we haven't strapped for
district and
it's up Seng superb because compared to
other districts I can tell counselors we
have fantastic product iron vehicles and
lightness as well however I think it's
time we started taking review of this
policy if in the long term we want
operators change from diesel to electric
vehicles because in all along state they
direct the extra expense of electric
vehicles
it's very prohibitive for a lot of small
independent operators it's probably fine
for a handful of big operators we have
here the other issue is as they point
out we are now suffering here from a
stealth invasion of uber drives from
Wolverhampton Council like other local
authorities I've tried to see the mounts
album even now of that and there again
their regulators are a lot looser
licensing a lot longer for the vehicles
they don't have the stringent checks
like we do for drivers for vehicles I
want us to have the safest vehicles with
the safest checks for drivers possible
but I think we have to start realizing
later that we need to review this policy
now and be looking to how we can assist
these operators in the future thank you
I think you are absolutely right there
will need to be a wholesale review of
this area we will focus on emissions but
the point here is councillor homage at
absolutely spot-on I would imagine there
will be a thorough review of this area
going forward councillor Huggins
thank you just actually just a small
statement I just wanted to thank the
Town Council I think it's particularly
Victoria Council Victoria Alacoque for
the absolutely magnificent lights that
are adorning beautiful town they are
outstanding in fact I would go so far to
say breathtaking and I'm sure helped
with the great popularity visitors
coming into the various market so thank
you very much indeed can I just take the
opportunity to endorse fully well
councillor Wally Hogan said well done
council all can I just remind all
councils that the questions the leaders
should be addressed to the leader please
accept my humble apologies Thank You
Costa O'Donnell
thank you it was just to go back to the
homeless discussion previously I second
counselor Ross and counselor or Cox
concern a garden current situation I'm
not sure if I didn't hear you clearly
cancer off but sick Gregory's Roman
Catholic Church has been hosting soups
and in a chat for a couple of years now
and actually took over United Reformed
Church couldn't facilitate during the so
I'm not sure if you're aware of that and
also one thing that came out of
discussing the last soup some dinner
chat was that the various voluntary
organisations involved her to clash with
when they're providing food etc so
you'll have two sessions on one day than
nothing for a few days so it's about
tried to coordinate them more closely as
well but I wanted it noted that st.
Gregory's have been involved for the
past couple of years and I think
sometimes it doesn't get mentioned as
important it's noted thank you
: Foreman
Thank You chairman leader could I ask as
the Victorian Christmas market was so
successful this year will we be
supporting the event in the future I
think the answer to that is a very
definite yes I did I'll have to say limp
around the Christmas market and it was
absolutely packed and I was impressed
with a number of variety of stalls I
understand that the numbers this year
were quite noticeably on the previous
year and that the impression I get that
this is becoming a very significant
event that an awful lot of people look
forward to I'm booking to their Diaries
early so yes it is a wonderful event for
stratford-on-avon town and I think in
fairness for the wider district any
other questions for the leader nope in
which case we move on to notice of
motion and this has been proposed by
council rock and seconded by councillor
Curtis yes we counsel curtis being
absent is unable to second it so do you
have a rub sorry we need the monitoring
officer to help a little call be
pedantic but
yeah that's my job
because councillor Curtis isn't here and
because he was second in the motion the
the normal rule is that you can't
proceed with the diverting of this
matter to cabinet however however there
is a slip rule that allows you to
suspend most of the individual rules
within the council procedure rule
including this one that I'm talking
about its rule fifteen point one so as
there are more than half of the members
here if you choose to you can suspend
rule fifteen point one to enable council
to send this to cabinet without the
necessity of having councillor Curtis
formally here to second the proposal I
hope that's clear are all the council
happy to follow that a new word slip
rule to allow it to get this proposal to
go towards cabinet but we are we
comfortable yes thank you
now apart from mr. ish do we have to
show of hands on this right on the basis
that we are comfortable that this should
be allowed to be slipped in accordance
with the guidance issued by the monetary
officer this will only happen for this
to go to cabinet as put forward by mr.
Rock and seconded by the absolute mr.
Curtis counselor ms Royal Council Curtis
yep okay we move on to I just leave you
to note the financial performances on
the back page of your agenda sheet
gender papers there are no items of
urgent business other than to wish all
counselors and all members of star press
and done and those who
really other way in this in this office
a very very happy Christmas I have the
chairman of right a few mince pies at
the back and some red and white wine for
those of you who are uncomfortable with
eating normal mince pies there are I
think a vegan and a vegetarian
gluten-free option at the back of the
table I had to be advised by Claire
Johnson on that matter but there are
some for those of you want something
slightly different so very happy
Christmas and we look forward to seeing
you in 2020
unless hope is a very vibrant year for
the council thank you